oui
[Musique]
depuis on donne en virginie me rejoint
la directrice de la campagne en faveur
des ouigours chaîne abbas roshan merci
de nous rejoindre dans notre émission la
semaine dernière nous avons pu voir ou
en bio du center for china globalisation
a renié tout génocide au xinjiang
combien de membres de la minorité
ouïghoure sont détenus collante et ce à
l'heure actuelle plus de 3 millions de
ouïghours sont détenues dans les camps
de concentration spiked si vous parlez à
n'importe quel ouigours de la diaspora
il a un ou plusieurs membres de sa
famille qui ont été arrêtés la famille
entière de mon mari a été déporté à
autant sera le sud de la région où
vivent la majeure partie de wii cours
mes beaux parents mais trois belles
soeurs et leurs maris mon beau frère et
sa femme ainsi que les 14 neveux et
nièces de mon mari 24 membres
la famille entière a disparu ma propre
soeur a disparu depuis septembre 2018
elle a été clairement arrêtée par
vengeance
à cause de mon travail de
sensibilisation ici aux etats-unis qu'à
t as
j'ai parlé à l'un des think tank de
washington le hudson institutes le 5
septembre 2018
six jours plus tard ma soeur et ma tante
est enlevé dans deux villes différentes
en réponse au fait que juste de ma
liberté d'expression aux états unis en
tant que citoyenne américaine
c'est le cas pour tous ouigours de la
diaspora
donc il ya plus de 3 millions de
ouïghours et dans des camps de
concentration
le tube est pour des changements de
régime un peu partout sur la planète
mais vous dites 3 millions qu'elle est
la population du xinjiang
car si ces 12 millions si on en croit
les chiffres de la bbc cela veut dire
qu'un quart de la population est détenu
oui oui mais je veux dire combien est ce
que ça coûterait au gouvernement chinois
sans même parler des violations des
droits de l'homme que cela
représenterait chine quand vous regardez
le recensement du gouvernement chinois
12 millions mais si vous prenez le
recensement ouigours il y à plus de 20
millions de wii
j'ai entendu parler de 25
donc qu'il ya eu une incroyable
augmentation de la population ouïghoure
depuis 2000 quand ils n'étaient que 8 4
millions 8,4 millions c'est que c'est le
recensement les chiffres des chinois du
gouvernement chinois
en réalité en 2004 la population
ouïghoure et de 25 millions 25 millions
nos intellectuels ouigours ont fait
leurs comptes recensement il y a cinq en
2016 il y avait plus de 20 millions de
ouïghours
alors que le gouvernement chinois parlé
de seulement 11 millions
ok et donc là où on en est c'est que
vous considérez qu'un quart de la
population ouïghoure et détenu vaucois
lorsque des journalistes de différentes
parties du globe ont pu se rendre dans
le xinjiang en août 2009
ils n'ont trouvé aucune preuve de
génocide ou de détention de la haye en
novembre 2019 la banque mondiale s'y est
rendu et a trouvé aucune preuve de
violations des droits de l'homme
sans même parler d'un génocide n est
fait vous vous sevrer de comment durant
l'holocauste
si vous avez vieux des images et des
films les nazis avaient fait toute une
mise en scène pour les gens de la croix
rouge venu en observateur taquet c'est
la même chose
en gros le gouvernement chinois met en
scène amène des acteurs des gens qui
sont coachés pour dire ce qu'ils doivent
dire montrer leur joie dans ses ouailles
mais quand vous regardez la réalité les
ouigours doit faire face à des mariages
forcés les femmes ouïghours sont forcés
de se marier à des ânes et si elle
refuse on les traite d'extrémisme les
fans ouigours feront face à des viols de
masse à la contraception obligatoire à
la stérilisation forcée à la torture au
lavage de cerveau au travail forcé à des
prélèvements d'organes
des crématoriums sont construits à côté
des camps de concentration pour une
culture qui ne pratiquent pas la
crémation
nous sommes musulmans n'avons pas
recours à la crémation
donc tout cela prend la direction d'un
génocide de toute évidence il ya
beaucoup de mauvais journalistes donc ce
que vous dites c'est que ces
journalistes ne savent pas ce qui se
passe en réalité vous avez travaillé à
la prison de guantanamo où il ya eu des
cas de torture et vous dites que la
situation pire ou chine jiang que
lorsque vous travaillez pour le
gouvernement américain facilitant la
torture à guantanamo
ce ne sont pas mes mots concernant la
situation dans le turkestan oriental
xinjiang
sommes nous appelle le régime chinois
non la situation non pas dans les camps
de concentration mais pour les gens
normaux comme la jeunesse au moi même
est pire que celle des détenus de
guantanamo sont les mots d'anciens
prisonniers ouïgours de guantanamo et 21
noms 22 ouïghours
j'ai travaillé comme traductrice
ouïghours et interprétez vous portiez un
uniforme militaire à guantanamo n'a que
la torture oui j'étais juste traductrice
ce contrat mais au début tous les civils
portaient un uniforme et étaient
considérés comme des contractuels j'ai
les images le prouvent en je ne faisais
pas partie de l'armée mais je suis très
heureuse d'avoir pu fournir un soutien
linguistique assez 22 ouïghours
innocents de les avoir soutenus car
hésité à accuser à tort à cause de la
situation chez eux ils avaient fui les
persécutions n'avait aucune sympathie
pour al qaïda il n'avait aucune
sympathie pour al qaïda et les attentats
du 11 septembre
ces ouïghours qui se trouvait à
guantanamo c'est un taux de oui gour
n'avait rien à voir avec les attentats
du 11 septembre il n'avait rien à voir
avec les terroristes
ces ouïghours avaient désespérément
besoin d'un soutien linguistique et ils
m'ont même demandé de les traduire pour
les défendre ainsi je les ai aidés je
les ai soutenus pour leur libération
c'est le gouvernement chinois qui les
accusent d'être des terroristes
vous voyez ces accusations quand vous
invoquez le low cost sommes de toute
évidence quand on en vient à invoquer
les génocides ce genre d' atteinte aux
droits de l'homme
c'est exactement ce que les états unis
ont fait pour justifier les guerres en
libye en afghanistan en syrie en irak en
amérique latine je sais qu'on vous l'a
déjà demandé mais pourquoi acceptez-vous
les financements de la fondation
nationale d'aumône faute démocratie
connaissant la brutalité les dizaines de
millions de victimes tuées ou blessés
torturés ou déplacées dans le monde à
cause des politiques du national
endowment for democracy
eh bien nous avons monté la campagne
pour les ouigours à l'automne 2010 secte
pour sensibiliser à ces atroces
atteintes aux droits de l'homme sans
précédent depuis l'holocauste
nous avons fondé cette campagne à
l'automne 2017
ma soeur a été enlevé en septembre 2018
j'ai quitté mon emploi à plein temps de
directrice du développement
international pour une société de
consulting pour laquelle je travaillais
et je suis devenue activiste à plein
temps un an exactement après
l'enlèvement de master financée par le
national endowment for democracy
je veux dire nous avons commencé à être
financés à partir d'octobre 2010 neuf
donc la campagne pour les bigots ne
perçoit pas d'argent du national
endowment for democracy
non absolument pas absolument pas vous
pouvez regarder nos comptes publics
j'avais un emploi à plein temps et je
suis lancé moi-même l'organisation nous
donnant la capacité d'être la voix de
ces millions d'ouïghours qu'on n'entend
pas de ces millions de gens qui
souffrent c'est tout ce qui m'importe
est tout ce que je sais tous ces gens
qui m'accusent de travailler pour la cia
de percevoir de l'argent d'une aide sont
des apologistes du génocide sont
exactement les mots que le ministre
chinois des affaires étrangères utilise
il y a à peu près un an le porte parole
du ministère chinois des affaires
étrangères zaho li jian a publiquement
31 utilisant précisément ces mots là il
a essayé de me diaboliser et de
discréditer mon travail ça ne va pas du
parti communiste chinois
il faut que je vous demande avez vous
été liés ou êtes-vous liés à la cia
absolument pas parce qu'on peut lire
dans votre biographie sur le site d'ici
consulting que vous avez l'expérience
d'avoir travaillé avec diverses agences
américaines de renseignement avec l
agence américaine de renseignement avez
vous travaillé je ne pense pas qu'on
lise agences de renseignement des
ministères elle a aussi une grande
expérience dans la collaboration avec le
département de la sécurité intérieure le
département de la défense le pentagone
oui et diverses agences américaines de
renseignement avec l agence américaine
de renseignement ou avez vous travaillé
quand je travaillais pour le bureau
d'architectes et les eaux à dali notre
entreprise à design et le qg du fbi aïe
ça c'était un travail de développement
de notre business et j'ai travaillé avec
le département de la défense avec le
secrétariat d'état
avec la sécurité intérieure pour la
libération de ces 22 détenus ouïghours
de guantanamo
j'ai travaillé avec eux j'ai soutenu ses
22 ouïghours
quand vous travaillez au sein de
l'entreprise militaire l3 pour tighten
consulting qui a été impliqué dans le
scandale de torture vous étiez
traductrice vous n'aviez rien à voir
avec la torture c'est exact était
torturé ensuite il disait
10 vous traduisez le problème ici comme
vous savez je traduisais pour toutes les
agences à guantanamo parce qu'elle
interrogé ses 22 ouïghours
je traduisais j'étais contractuels pour
elle trois en tant que traductrice que
ce soit titans ou l3 je travaillait
comme traductrice
j'ai été embauché comme consultante
je veux dire comme consultant
linguistique je traduisais j'étais un
soutien linguistique pour ce 22
ouïghours
larry wilkinson qui a été chef
d'état-major de collines powell et qui
est venu dans cette émission dit que le
chemin pour un changement de régime
en chine les etats unis ont 400 bases
militaires qui encerclent la chine à
l'heure actuelle passe par le xinjiang
voyez-vous pourquoi des membres de votre
famille et vous dites qu'il s'agissait
de vengeance basse à votre militantisme
voyez-vous pourquoi votre soeur pourrait
être des plus hauts choisiraient de ne
pas vous parler au regard de vos liens
avec le complexe militaro-industriel
américain boîte
ma soeur a deux filles
les deux et vivent aux états unis
ma soeur est un médecin à la retraite
mais ok laissez-moi l'instant revenir en
arrière je suis sans voix face à ces
accusations
je suis absolument sans voix donc quand
j'ai soulevé le cas de ma soeur en
décembre 2018
vous savez j'ai parlé très ouvertement
après l'enlèvement de ma soeur en
septembre 2018 je me suis fait entendre
j'ai mis en avant le cas de ma soeur
décembre 2019
le média d'état chinois global times
m'accuse d'avoir des photos d'autres
personnes et de m'inventer une soeur et
ils ont attaqué notre organisation
vous pouvez vérifier je peux vous
envoyer un lien
après les deux filles de ma soeur qui
vivent aux états unis ont appris que
leur mère avait été condamné à une
lourde peine de prison en mars 2010 neuf
9 mois avant que médias d'état chinois
publicité chose contre moi et notre
organisation
vous savez ces tentatives de dire que ma
soeur ne voudrais pas me parler évoqué
les changements de régime
ceci cela tout cela ce sont des attaques
grotesque pour discréditer mon travail
et me déshumanisé sow agace donc je
pense que mon message a été clair
concernant le génocide
je ne parle pas seulement de ma soeur ma
soeur est dans un camp de concentration
je parle des trois lots de documents qui
ont fuité trois lots de documents
officiels du gouvernement chinois
évoquant les actions génocidaire du
gouvernement chinois
nous espérons que vous retrouverez
bientôt votre soeur le gouvernement
chinois dément tout génocide dans le
xinjiang
roshan abbas merci après la pause le
procès de la sphère georges floyd et ce
qui est vraiment en jeu
[Musique]
sommes de retour alors que l'armée
américaine continue de dépenser l'argent
des contribuables américains partout sur
la planète les hommes politiques
américains retourne au sénat et le débat
se focalise sur l'intérieur les
etats-unis sont-ils dé facto un pays
d'apartheid se demandent certains alors
que les chaînes de télévision diffusent
le procès du policier et tueur présumé
de georges tron me rejoint maintenant du
new-jersey l'un des plus influents
penseurs conservateurs américains
le professeur de jurisprudence à
l'université de princeton roberts george
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous le monde
entier regarde ce procès comment voyez
vous les réactions à ce qui semble être
un déclin depuis des années aux états
unis de la loi et de l'éthique il avait
avec ces choses qui n'a pas décliné la
plupart des américains de la plupart des
races veulent que monsieur chauvin est
un procès équitable et festive et
coupable de meurtre il doit être
condamné pour meurtre il est reconnu
coupable des chefs moins graves
d'homicides involontaires il veut le
voir condamné pour cela est fini s'il
n'est pas coupable
ils veulent le voir à qui tu es j'espère
que la volonté des américains encore une
fois de toutes races de toutes ethnies
prévaudra quand on aura le verdict si on
met de côté le procès les entreprises
les institutions gouvernementales et les
forces de police
ici au royaume uni mais je sais que
c'est aussi le cas aux états unis qu'on
souhaitait organiser des cours des cours
obligatoires sur les races et sur le
genre vous ne pensez pas que c'est la
solution aux atrocités qu'on a pu
constater ces dernières années aux états
unis
il n'y a pas de preuve qu'il marche
qu'ils atteignent les buts pour lesquels
ils sont conçus je suis de surpoids très
inquiet pour ce qui est des libertés
civiles a aidé que de tels cours se
transforme en camp de rééducation comme
une fille devienne une forme
d'endoctrinement quand un seul point de
vue et présenter pour des questions sur
lesquelles des gens raisonnables de
bonne volonté ne sont pas d'accord il ya
beaucoup de questions relatives à la
race à la police la violence sur
lesquelles des gens raisonnables de
bonne volonté
ils seront pas d'accord quant à l'unique
point de vue est le seul autorisé et
quand il est obligatoire que ce point de
vue soit enseignée ça ressemble à mon
sens ça de l'endoctrinement ce week end
et je n'aime pas ça en place je ne ferai
pas cela moi même je suis même pas
d'accord que certaines universités
autorise cela sur leur campus jeudi il
devrait y avoir un débat durant lequel
les gens devraient être en mesure de
confronter différents points de vue vous
souhaitez essayer de se persuader les
uns les autres à l'aide d'un discours
intellectuellement approprié raison
preuves et arguments des femmes mais au
delà des aspects les plus inquiétants
vous ne pensez pas qu'il ya quelque
chose de plus profond
ici concernant la conception qu'ont les
gens de ce que veut dire et être un être
humain peut apprendre en un cours de 5
minutes que tuer un innocent n'est pas
bien ce genre de court je vois où vous
voulez en venir
et vous avez raison ce qui est en jeu
sans ce dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
est très profond
cela touche la notion même d'êtres
humains à ce que les universitaires m
appeler l'anthropologie philosophique de
la plus grande importance que le débat
soit un débat est libre et ouvert auquel
n'a posions pas les points de vue et que
nous ne roulions pas obligatoire un
point de vue spécifique ou le donner un
monopole ou devient maintenant un pont
ou du gain est ce que vous diriez que
légiférer contre les discriminations
légiférer contre ce genre de choses qui
font partie du débat aux états unis mais
pas le chemin qui mène à une meilleure
société
il faut quelque chose d'autre
je pense qu'il ya de l'espace pour une
législation antidiscrimination
classiques comme le sida act de 1964
ici aux etats-unis stakes mais il ne
doit pas y avoir de doctrine
tout le monde devrait être contre le
racisme car le racisme est tout
simplement contraire aux principes de
base qu'est la dignité profonde
égalitaire genève où l'humain de chaque
membre de la famille l'humanité c'est au
coeur de notre système politico
juridique
c'est au coeur des votre royaume uni le
problème est que d'un point de vue
concret dans l'application de ce
principe des gens raisonnables de bonne
volonté ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
et on ne peut pas laisser un quand
tyranniser laisser un camp contrôlé
l'autre camp et s'imposer nous avons
besoin d'un débat approprié dans lequel
nous pouvons tous faire part de nos
arguments public essayer de persuader
nos concitoyens nous arrivera de gagner
qui nous arrivera de perdre mais n'y a
pas de victoire ou de défaite permanente
parce que dans une société démocratique
on peut toujours revenir et dire écoutez
ça ne marche pas nous avons fait une
erreur il faut retoucher la loi il faut
repenser les choses
revenons en arrière et reprenons sur les
bas mais si on parle disons de la
cupidité des entreprises
croyez en la régulation pourquoi ne
pensez vous pas que la régulation marche
de la même manière pour ce qui est des
croyances vide et qui oppriment d'autres
minorités aux majorités dans différents
pays ou encore le souhait bien sûr on
arrive aux problèmes des gens
raisonnables ou en désaccord quant à ce
qui constitue une oppression ce qui
constitue une micro agression ou même ce
qui est bien ou mal
nous avons même des désaccords
fondamentaux concernant même ce qui fait
d'une personne un homme ou une femme de
nos jours ce ne sont pas des désaccords
que nous avions auparavant c'est un
désaccord tout nous avons aujourd'hui
et essayer de faire faire un camp est
tout simplement une sorte de tyrannie
est contraire aux principes de base des
libertés civiques pour lesquelles nos
sociétés se base je ne vous vise pas
vous laisser seulement vous pour ça mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe il vend pas
totalement mais en partie cornel west
était récemment dans cette émission
comme je comprends il s'est vu refuser
certaines nominations aux états unis il
y à de nombreux exemples de gens à qui
on a refusé certaines places dans des
académies à cause de leur position de
leurs écrits et travaux universitaires
pourquoi ne les avez vous pas sauvé
pourquoi si peu de gens protestent pour
sauver les gens au nom de la liberté des
idées et pensées universitaires un
enseignement et bien écoutez je n'ai
sauvé personne tout seul j'ai été
impliqué dans la défense de certaines
personnes qui en ont sauvé quelques
autres et j'en suis fier
mais ça n'est pas assez trop de gens
sont victimes de la can sur la culture
trop de gens sont discriminés on leur
refuse de manière totalement
déraisonnable à cause de leurs croyances
leur religion de leurs opinions
politiques des positions pour lesquels
ils sont tout à fait qualifié
je ne suis pas dit si moi-même en dépit
du fait que je suis conservateur que je
suis chrétien que je suis catholique
j'ai une vie universitaire merveilleuse
je n'en suis pas victime mais d'autres
le sont rogers crotone a été victime des
deux côtés de l'atlantique en cause de
ses positions conservatrices
justement on lui a refusé des postes
universitaires qu'il aurait dû avoir et
si cela peut arriver à quelqu'un qui est
au maximum des capacités intellectuelles
cambridge aux côtés quelqu'un que
n'importe quel département de
philosophie dans le monde aurait dû être
fiers de compter parmi les siens du jeu
cela peut arriver absolument n'importe
qui dans le monde universitaire et ne
devrait pas être ainsi donc qu'est ce
que j'ai fait j'ai participé à la
création d'une nouvelle organisation
pour contre attaquer elle s'appelle
l'académique freedom alliance
j'encourage les gens à se rendre sur
notre site internet academic freedom
point orchidées vous verrez comment deux
cents d'entre nous des conservateurs
comme moi jusqu'à des progressistes
comme quant à l'ouest s'allient pour
combattre la can seule culture
combattez discriminations auxquels font
face les gens dans les universités quand
ils prétendent à des postes et qu'on
leur refuse une à cause de l'opposition
boys
je sais ce que je dois dire que ce
scrutin venait régulièrement dans cette
émission avant sa mort c'était deux
grandes mais pour aller plus loin
pourquoi une telle culture est elle
apparue
comment comprenez vous que à mesure
qu'on découvrait les crimes du
communisme soviétique l'a dit gauche se
soit réfugié dans les questions
identitaires et l'utilisation de
l'université et des postes dans les
universités comme des arbres pour faire
la société qui le veulent plutôt que la
lutte des classes qui était précédemment
le principal moteur du progrès c'est une
histoire longue et compliquée que je ne
suis pas sûr de parfaitement comprendre
de manière évidente le marxisme
classique a échoué nombreuses personnes
de nombreux universitaires en était
partisan ils ont eu pendant un certain
temps
la théorie de la conscience de classe de
l'ouvrier est donc une sorte de
révisionnistes de marxisme révisionniste
s'est installé à ses taux au sein de la
gauche
vous pouvez le voir dans le travail de
personnalités importantes comme antonio
gramsci theodor adorno ou encore max
horkheimer j'ai une querelle ou plutôt
en désaccord avec certains de mes amis
conservateurs à ce sujet beaucoup de
conservateurs pensent que le problème
fondamental qui mène aux questions
identitaires alla kane sur la culture et
à cette attitude tyrannique ce que tant
de gens épouse et à gauche qui pense que
ça spécifiquement à voir avec
l'idéologie progressiste ou de gauche
j'ai tendance à penser et je suis là un
peu et hrithik que c'est un problème de
nature humaine les gens aiment leurs
propres opinions nos émotions sont liés
à ces trois tu mens à nos convictions et
quand le lien est trop étroit cela peut
mener à une sorte de dogmatisme
c'est vrai pour les conservateurs pour
les libéraux pour les religieux pour les
laïcs
c'est la nature humaine quand on voit la
perspective de décrocher un monopole
pour nos positions et mettre les
positions concurrentes en dehors du
circuit
on est tellement émotionnellement
investi dans nos propres opinions sont
les aime encore plus que la vérité ou le
conte succombe souvent la tentation de
mettre les autres de côté de les
supprimer je prendre ce monopole et de
le conserver foule depuis points gal
roule vers cela arrive à gauche en ce
moment parce qu'ils ont le monopole
culturel la droite avait le pouvoir
culturel la même chose serait sans doute
en train d'arriver au quai certains
diront que c'est à gauche et membre de
la gauche disons que non et d'autres
encore pourraient dire que c'est bénin
par rapport à ce qui nous a amenés à
avoir cette conversation la violence
vale la révolution américaine
il y a des balles à ce n'est pas tout à
fait bénin est d'accord mais qu'il
s'agisse de la révolution américaine de
la révolution française comme aspect
madison vous faites partie du madison
programme
je pense que la révolution américaine a
connu son lot de violence je voudrais
juste il faudra vous inviter à nouveau
pour discuter de ça en détail
j'ai vu que vous aviez twitté au sujet
de chomsky vous partager ses convictions
quant à la liberté d'expression et l'a
aussi été dans cette émission
pourquoi ne partagez vous passez à
conviction qu'il ya aussi une fabrique
du consentement qui est bien plus
totalitaire et développé aux états unis
et qu'il en a été ainsi bien avant cette
quand celle culture il ya une formidable
mobilité sociale aux états unis il en a
été ainsi historiquement just ce sport
nous avons nos injustice mais nos idéaux
sont louables
on peut lire l'intégralité de l'histoire
des états unis comme une histoire
d'injustice ou d'oppression s'ils ont eu
match mais ça n'est pas une lecture
correcte il est bien plus correct de
comprendre notre histoire commune de
lutte eu lieu de contre l'oppression
contre les pratiques trop courante qui
vont à l'encontre de nos principes
fondamentaux et avant tout à l'encontre
du principe de dignité de chaque mois
membre de la famille d'humanité il est
énoncé dans notre déclaration qu'il est
une évidence que tous les hommes sont
nés égaux et dispose de certains droits
inaliénables
j'en suis un bénéficiaire je suis le
premier de ma famille avoir fait des
études
ce type de mobilité sociale reflète le
meilleur des états unis et c'est très
répandu
si je regarde mes confrères au sein du
monde universitaire à princeton
il faut des gens au top de leur carrière
ils ne sont pas dans l'ensemble des gens
venant de familles aisées fermé beaucoup
de membres de l'université sont juifs
certains chrétiens il ya de plus en plus
de musulmans
ils peuvent tous arriver au top du monde
universitaire et on constatera la même
chose si on se penche sur le monde de
l'entreprise sur les cabinets d'avocats
et sur d'autres professions j'aime ce
pays
ces principes ce qu'on a réussi à faire
cette lutte dans laquelle nous sommes
lancés pour vaincre les injustices à
commencer par l'esclavagé il injustice
envers les amérindiens la lutte contre
gil troy
j'aime la vision de martin luther king
la fraternité universelle des hommes
sous la paternité de dieu
voilà mon amérique je veux que cette
amérique survivent prospère et a été
mise en mieux professeur georges merci
[Musique]
je